Okay, oh sh*t I FORGOT. OH MY GOD! Hold on one second, guys!
OH NO
LWIAY
*WAAA sound effect*
We have LWIAY merch
Imagine watching LWIAY while wearing LWIAY
Okay, very epic
Sorry JacksFilms, it's not just Fortnite...
*laughs*
...that's gonna rip you off
The hundred... it's just a complete coincidence, all right?
It's not that we thought we would hit a 100 million way quicker, okay?
The hundred is there for a random number.
All right, cool
Epic merch, check out link in description
Now let's just LWIAY!
*LWIAY Theme*
(Subtitle by *I am HeRe* in description at bottom)
Keanu Leaves
"Overall, your Keanu Leaves is a wonder!
What a breathtaking Pokemon!"
That's a good meme
Keanu Memes still going strong! Week 3 baby!
"I don't want to kill a child"
"Alright fine, baby. You can sleep with me tonight"
"Everyone liked tha-" HAHA
I have a feeling there's gonna be a lot of Minecraft memes in here
I'm very excited. "#1 Trending, Game Theory. YouTube Is Ruining Gaming"
*laughs*
"Minecraft Part 1. Don't do that... Don't give me hope"
But there is Minecraft part 2, 3 & 4 I think.
Too bad Gaming Week is over.
that's right, gamers recognize real
Thank you guys. Who said I wasn't a gamer?
Have you seen my house in Minecraft? Dude? It's got flowers on the outside
Are you serious? Did we hit 96,696,969?
How did I not notice this? That's amazing!
That's what we need to put on the merch
"One percent are shaking in their boots"
"99 percent of people in this sub would
support a full Minecraft Let's Play"
If this video gets a million likes, I'll bring back Gaming Week, alright?
I'll make it Gaming Week Supreme. I painted Keanu Reeves because he is breathtaking
Beautiful
When you scroll so far down
you start seeing blue shirt kid again
Basically, it's the YouTube algorithm
"Please, Felix"
*reads*
Jesus Christ...
1 million...!
Gaming Week... CONTINUES!
Gaming Week Supreme
1 million likes and buying ALL the merch
That's all I ask
I don't think that's that much to ask
*reads*
That's right
If you cut down a tree you must plant two more
That's the rules
It's all Minecraft memes
*reads*
WhAaTt?!
Alright, sorry, I didn't know you can't walk over your crops!
I didn't know what applies to Minecraft applies to real life. Guys! We have bags, okay? 1 million
This could be you
1 million
Hell yeah I need secret achievement
*reads*
wWHHaaTT?
I'm really glad you guys enjoyed, 'cause I'm genuinely having fun, too
That's epic. Gamers supporting gamers. Gamer supporting gamers on Gaming Week
#1 Trending #1 Trending
"I'm beginning to see a pattern here that I like"
That's just confusing. I was like, I swear I've said that — Oh right, it's me
What the hell is this easter egg?
Okay, fine. I'll do it!
8 years! 8 years!
That's...crazy dude, it's pretty cool actually
Like I never thought of it, like coming back to a game you haven't played in so long
That's been continually updating
"WhAt iS tHaT?"
WhAAT?
There's horses in Minecraft?! Oh, god, please stop goddammit. Alright, here we go again
Me plus the boys at 2 AM lookin' for beans
Gamer approves. Thanks for making it easy for me
Don't you dare tell them! x2
*Bruh sound effect #2*
AND PewDiePie. Cool. I'm glad we settled that
ME AND THE BOIZ
That's awesome! Upvote!
Listen has anyone tried planting the eggs? Why would you put a bed in the Nether?
Ok? Sometimes you don't know until you try. How did the first chicken was born?
Well, what came first, the chicken or the egg?
Well, the egg was planted... then the chicken came
Like these guys know as much
about Minecraft than I do
There's only one person that I'll ever play Minecraft with and it's James Charles goddammit
Kawaiiiiii!
Yeah
I don't know what gravel is
What's gravel gravel gravel in Swedish?"Grus"?
gRuS??!! Oh god, I'm actually that dumb. I didn't know I didn't know
"Never dig straight down"— It's literally all Minecraft
Cool, it's the frog, meme ruined
See, I don't — how am I supposed to know these things? What do I do in the village?
Help me!
I think we've been trending every single day this week
I kind of want to let him go
Can you do it? What happens if you let him in?
Friendly reminder that there are currently 69 days till Dr. Phil turns 69
Hell yeah, my man!
My honey, my boo
Walking on crop — how am I — goddamit...
What is this? Oh the flint — the lava and the obsidian — and what else? The GRAVEL come on
Goddammit! Why do you guys like me playing if I'm doing everything wrong?
Oh damn, I never thought of that
Only real gamers remember
God damn it! Can this meme die, please? Thank you~
Oh, yeah
F's in the chat boys
Alright guys, there can be other memes as well, like not Minecraft
Jesus Christ
What's bedrock?
Right-handed redditors trying to reach the upvote button....
DAMN!!
Yeah, well, how are you gonna scroll? You can't scroll like that. Oh
Yeah, this is how I look, dummies
Fake post, downvote!
I don't know what I'm doing!! I am the veteran, PAY RESPECT. Oh you were in your dad's balls?
I was making diamond pickaxes. Give me some goddamn respect
Yeah, you guys really didn't like Fortnite did ya?
Oh my god I  can't believe Belle Delphine tricked us! WHHAAAT?
Minecraft is the game that brings me back
Minecraft is gonna be my redemption arc
Listen, I'm not that bad of a chef in real life
Okay? I swear
You guys are obsessed!
Wait, there's people actually named Jørgen?
cringe
Oh my god, this it sO rAcIsT!
It's "chjip chjöp"! Get it right
Goddammit
I'm just getting roasted! What is this??!!
OKaY, alRiGht!
I don't know!
OKAY!
Goddammit...
I don't get it.
*sigh*
Hello, tiny horse!
Why is the creeper living in the daylight? That makes no sense
Creepers can live in daylight?
Goddammit. It looks like a cactus!!
Please kitty farmer, pLeasE
True intellectuals
That is so sweet
Goddamnnn boy!
Goddamn, look at Edgar!!
Look at the Italian leather!
Damn look at the detail
goddamn
so cute!! x2
That is amazing
"Meme Review" "100"!
That's amazing
Wait, you can give diamond armor to horses?? That's awesome!!
Alright
Remember the rules: check out merch Gaming Week Supreme and let's freaking get the gamer bread, bros
Thanks for this week's LWIAY. I see you next week. Bye!
WHAt?! You've never played Tuber Simulator?!
You know, it's fun, right?
I'm not supposed to give my opinion, but give it a try. And then you can tell me if it's good or not
Not convinced yet? Okay, I'll cut you a deal. The game is available for free and that's a great price!!!